Um, well, I love the echo and it's,
it's a big echo chamber. We're in.
Well, sort of. Yeah. Hey, I'm
Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab, the podcast and uh,
we're coming to you on the podcast,
not from our usual space,
which is the studio in New York now or
in La and we're sitting on a stage in
Chits Royce Hall and on the campus of
UCLA. We're on tour. So we have a show,
a live show that we do. We can't here,
couldn't get back to do our podcast in
the normal way so we can do it right here
on stage. Yeah, we here.
We wanted to actually just talk a little
bit about what's going to be happening
next week.
Next week we have this awesome show which
we call color because that's what it's
about.
It's about the nature and the
peculiarities and the anecdotals and the
everything of color ads, right?
We're going to explore all kinds of
things about the different colors, race,
very greens, yellows and
all the shades in between.
But we're going to play cool stuff right
now because here's the cool thing about
this, this show. Um, we, uh,
one of the experiments we're doing
for this colors podcast is, uh,
we are working with a ton of really
talented musicians who are going to be
playing a lot of color themed songs
and tons of tons of great musicians are
going to be on this hour including Reggie
Watts. You may remember him from a,
the curious sounds concert we
aired a couple of months ago.
Amazing Dude does this whole
like acapella looping situation.
She has him a Mike in a little box and
while we've actually been here, uh,
on tour, he was back in New York
city standing by, so we kind of,
we could kind of miss each
other. Can you guys hear me?
But we call them up on
our cell phones and uh,
yeah. Okay. There we go. Yeah, panel
chair. Okay. And we all hear each other.
Yes, I can hear, I can,
I can hear each other.
So I guess you're going to do
the Kermit song light. Yeah,
I'm going to attempt screens to,
yeah, I'll use those words of it.
So, Reggie, what does it
mean to be green? Well,
ecofriendly environment
is very important to me.
And the planet really needs help. No.
Um, I guess, uh, being being greed.
I don't, you know, I don't know.
I guess being green is like,
it's about being different. So I
guess, uh, it isn't easy being green.
It's not easy being yourself. Oh,
sorry. We can't be there to witness it.
Five in person. I'm pretty
relatively angry, but uh, it's okay.
All right, well thanks Reggie. They're
calling for us to go on stage there.
Yeah, we gotta we gotta run back
on there. Fine. Go do shows. Okay,
well good luck. Who can't wait to hear
it. All right guys. Thank you. Bye.
That was Rick Santorum and Gorph Garcon
talking about some of the classic
elements of w NYC right
here. We'll be right back.
You rolling it? Okay. Ready?
[inaudible]
okay, here we go. Chat.
ah,
so
you said
it's [inaudible] then you bed.
Let's see.
All the others. They might
[inaudible] just a little bit,
just little bit to me.
It's not p
three p is the
screen
[inaudible]
differences in the shade. It's
one little Whoa, Whoa,
ah,
cause look color the grounds
[inaudible] the trees.
Mostly the [inaudible]
that people have inside.
Really
the Emerald Castle
because on its main, yes.
[inaudible]
that was Richie watts
with being great. Okay.
You know that Radiolab is
listener supported, right?
We rely on you guys listening to people
who listen to this podcast to chip in to
help us pay for producing it. Hmm.
So we decided to start something a little
new to make this whole relationship a
little more fun. Yeah. We've
launched a brand new uh, radio lab.
Digital membership will offer you
exclusive access to a ton of mp3s that we
recorded for this color's show some
great online posters behind the scenes
videos and all kinds of things we're going
to be making for this in exchange for
$75. So you will have like several of
these songs that you can just, Oh yeah,
it's gonna be a bunch.
We record a lot of these songs and we're
gonna make a bunch of them available.
They're really, really
good. Hey, this is Soren,
a senior producer at regular lab
sitting in New York on tour in sunny Los
Angeles. But Jen, Robert asked me to, uh,
just toss a couple of the songs in here
so you could get a taste of what we're
offering with the whole
digital membership thing.
So the first five that we're
gonna offer up are, uh,
the flanks doing a beautiful bluegrass
version of the Beatles yellow submarine.
Okay.
You can gaze tearing up
new orders. Do Monday
[inaudible] got
Eric Friedlaender doing a
kind of classical treatment
of miles Davis is blue and
green.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] you got lost
the trees doing Nick Drake's pink moon
and homeboy Sandman and Giante doing an
original song called simply brown,
the saddles saddlebags coffee grounds.
But what is, send a camera in home,
staying up with the
house, easy down the road.
Snake oil, thousand feet beneath the soil,
no smoke. And that's
just a few of the songs.
We get tons more and you get all of
them for just 75 bucks if you become a
digital member. So back to a Jan Robert.
So please help us support the show.
Go to radiolab.org and click on become
a lab partner that's become a lab
partner. The lab. I'm a
partner of the lab. Yeah.
Thanks for listening to this podcast.
We've got our break next week,
our color show. We're really excited
about it coming very, very soon.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening. Let's go.
Thanks John.
[inaudible] agreement. One more
thing.
Big thanks to John De lure for recording
and mixing the podcast on the stage in
La and on the way out here is the
lonesome organist doing green onions.
[inaudible].